what's going on everybody welcome to the
twenty second intermediate Python
tutorial in this tutorial what we're we
covering is logging so logging is
actually part of the standard library so
everybody has it and what it does is
exactly what the name suggests it helps
you to log things mainly creating a log
file but you don't have to actually
create a log file so let's go ahead and
get into it so basically with logging
really the biggest thing that it does is
this helps with debugging and making
sure your program is working as you
might expect but probably the best term
for it is debugging but there are also
there's a low layer of debugging a level
of debug url'
a level of logging rather I'm gonna I'm
gonna interchange these terms on and
source what I'm warning about there's a
level of logging called literally debug
it's the lowest level basically and it's
just detailed information basically
everything your program is doing you
could you would anything that's like a
really miniscule piece of information
you would have it as debug Nega info
just basically things are working or
something's happening as you might
expect and they've got warning something
unexpected happened error something went
wrong but we're okay and then finally
critical some your you know like you're
basically going to throw an exception
and stop everything maybe save what that
exception was now we're logging is the
most useful is when you're gonna run
something unlike use like a server or
something like that where it's running
headless you're not actually viewing the
stream of output it can be really useful
to actually log that output and from
time to time check to make sure things
are happening and you're not hitting
errors that you weren't expecting but
then also if things crash you can go
back to the log file and read through
what what happened as things crashed and
if and what you can do with logging is
you can set certain levels so for
example let's let's go ahead an import
logging and then let's set up and
configure it so we can do logging basic
config camelcase their level equals
logging dot and we'll say info for now
so any log information that we say is
debug level under this configuration
won't actually log
I mean the codes there but it's not
gonna log because we're setting the
logging level to info so everything info
and above will log but the debug lay
level stuff just isn't gonna log either
it's not going to come to our console
and or or go to our file so but we can
change that so like let's say for some
reason something went really awry and we
don't know what's up and maybe we even
had it set toe just warning and then we
checked a log file and sure enough oh
we've got a lot of warnings in here but
we're not seeing exactly what's wrong
we might later decide ok let's set it to
debug run everything again and see
what's happening and so it's just a
really quick way to change one thing and
get a whole lot more information from
your program as opposed to the typical
you know you might be someone who who in
various areas of their functions or
classes or whatever might just issue
random print statements like got here
and stuff like that which can help
temporarily but it's a lot easier on
especially bigger projects if you're
making a bigger project to just bake
logging in immediately because in bigger
projects you're gonna have errors and
it's super nice and convenient to just
be able to be like ok duh bug level and
give me everything and stuff like that
so we'll leave it as a debug for now and
let's go ahead and add some things so
for example one one layer of debugging
you know that you might do is like let's
say in the add method this dunder add
let's say like every time the add method
is is invoked we want to actually log
that and would that be debugging
necessarily or would that be like
something higher than to bug right
basically you definitely want to be
really careful with log files because if
you if you set it to a level and then
let it log forever those log files just
grow infinitely in size and that can be
really problematic so you don't want to
put things like you've for sure the
lowest level of logging like the bug can
be stuff that's like constant just
it's just a huge stream of data but as
you get higher you really don't want to
be a constant room data otherwise you're
gonna literally run out of space on your
hard drive and just as a personal
anecdote I have had my my sequel log
files get so big that I run out of
storage on the server and then my sequel
stops working and then I'm busy trying
to figure out why is my sequel not
working when it's not working because
the log file got so huge that we just
can't make an insert statement anymore
we're out of space right and the
solution is just to make more space
actually nothing to do with my sequel no
issues with my sequel with a server it
was I ran out of space but because of
the log file so just as an example so
log files you've got to be careful
because you will you know you don't want
to shoot yourself in the foot so anyway
when we do an ADD operation these are
actually pretty rare so I mean they're
not rare but they're feeling far between
so I would probably not make it a
debugging level but I would probably do
logging mmm I would I would classify
this as an info okay so then we can put
some info we could say a blob add
operation those two pop and then we'll
do some string formatting here dot
format and then let's do the string
version of self dot color and the string
version of other blob doc color so we'll
get the two colors of strings now it
would be nice if we could say string
self and string blob but at the moment
we actually don't have that and possibly
in a later tutorial I will cover what
you can do to do like the literally
dunder string method and have it
actually work in your favor so you can
do things like string something and it
actually produces something of use as
opposed to right now it would just be
like some sort of blob object a blob
jecht anyway okay so I've got that info
there and let me go back up okay yeah so
we're not logging to a file yet
so now we'd be notified every time
there's a blob adding operation but
let's also add one more thing and let's
come down here and I think let's do here
so after we you know we're iterating
through the blue blobs and then all the
other blobs and then here is where we're
actually starting to compare them this
would be something you might want to
have logging but would you want it to be
info right this is gonna iterate every
frame through every single blob so this
would be one of the you know logging
debug okay something you you really need
it to be the lowest level possible
because you don't want to blow up your
files necessarily but maybe you want to
have this just in case something is
going wrong you could run it in maybe
and see exactly what's happening
throughout your entire program so anyway
let's say logging up bug checking if
blobs are touching and again dot format
string version of what do we say blue
blob blue blob dot media dot color that
doesn't really make much sense though I
don't really want to do we'll do color
for now again it would be so much more
useful to have a string method we will
almost certainly cover something like
because it just would it would help here
and then we'll do
what's it what it was either blob other
like ideally you would say stray another
blob and that string method would
contain information like the blob its
color and its location or something like
that that would be pretty darn useful
okay so logging dot bug will do that and
then finally let's go to the very bottom
in the wild true loop and let's add
let's just add it fry accepts exception
as E and then we could say and actually
this lets do
yeah well play this where you keep it
here so in the while true loop as long
as you have this exception handling the
true the while true loop will continue
going so it actually might make more
sense to in case the while true loop in
a try and except although if you really
want it to to stop looping this infinite
while loop what we can do is when we're
all done we can break so that'll work so
I'll just do that but really if you're
gonna do this you really probably
shouldn't case the while true loop and
try and accept but that's okay so now
here logging dot and since we're gonna
break here that would be a critical
error right because we're gonna stop it
from running when it hits this so
logging dot critical and then we really
can just string me here that's probably
good enough and break okay let's run it
and see if everything is working we are
at I think info was the level we chose
so hopefully we're not seeing massive
critical root tuple index out of range
what would be out of range
possibly in our
color I don't think that's a bad one
what about this one
if our logging operations are what
causes this I'm gonna be pretty okay
let's try this one so we can see at
least the add operation logging is
coming through now let's try to see what
is the issue with this one
logging dot debug checking if the dot
format did I close off the format here
is that what I've done but I'm not sure
how I go I got away with that other
parentheses I mean I go to the very very
end here and close this oops let's try
one more time okay so this is taking a
very long time because we're we're
literally logging everything for every
frame so it's gonna be pretty laggy so
let me close this now
I thought we set it to info no we said
it's a debug okay
well let's set to info because as you
can see that's outrageous okay so
everything's working and then hopefully
when two blobs kind of collide yep sure
enough just over here they collided and
looks like over here also they collided
and then we had a bunch of add
operations some couple blobs touched
each other for a while there okay so you
get the idea now it can be kind of
annoying to output that to console also
just to dish the show let's just do
watch your try let's do a plus B here
right and we see the critical the
critical one hasn't that stopped
everything now and in fact actually
since just to be a proper with PI game
we really should do PI game whoops tie
game quit and then quit
because because that's what should
happen when we exit pygame and since we
are calling this break we probably need
to throw that code in there there we go
much better much cleaner okay so I'm
gonna not have a a plus B and now let's
add going up to the top the
configuration we can add a an actual log
file so V is a file name equals log file
dot log cool let's save that run it and
now you won't see any the output to the
console instead it's actually coming to
through to the the actual log file
itself so let me pull that up real quick
okay so here is our log file currently
it's at oh I just updated oh what
immediately is gonna open up and just
starts appending things to the log file
so we can open it up and we can see yep
we've got a bunch of add operations
pretty much all the same there's one
different one here and so I'm just some
information those would obviously
initially until we start maybe somehow
adding new blobs maybe initially you get
a lot of these sad operations but over
time it would it would dwindle because
blobs are disappearing but you might
even set that that operation to a debug
it's just meant to be a simple example
here so let's say I'm debugging I just
wanted to show you it's super it's
probably something that's not necessary
on like smaller applications but if you
are building larger applications I can't
tell you how useful it's been I've only
like after spending like a hundred hours
on an application realize that I
probably should add logging into this to
make it better and it's kind of annoying
to add it after the fact so I just I
definitely recommend it if you know
you're getting into something large like
making a large website or something like
that it's super useful anyways that's
enough for now if you have any questions
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave them below another thing I'd like
to talk about is exception handling
right now the exception handling is
relatively weak especially because we're
a long
the exception so we'll probably touch on
that in a little bit but otherwise if
you have questions comments concerns
whatever suggestions leave them below
and I'll see you in another tutorial